cuz Chris O'Dowd very handsome Matt very
ha
but Colin Farrell beautiful right
beautiful matter yeah beautiful man
thank you for recognizing the
distinction I feel too great you see you
fight your beauty and you often use the
medium of hair to fight you already had
some of the worst hairdos in film no
genuine like a vampire magazine did top
10 worst hairdos and film I'm definitely
three of those like Horrible Bosses is
intentional and that's one of the three
I was talking about movie I love home at
the end of the world
Thanks it's just such a good movie and
you're so good in it however that's
having hampered like I mean that's a
testament I oughta mess I was at the
time that I actually stood in front of a
camera without a man to dinner with her
[Applause]
the most famous is of course this one in
Alexander which there's worse pictures
they're not from Alexander that's
actually not bad that was my Doris Day
look you're so not a blonde I mean it
did seem a big decision to make
Maria's Alexander famously blonde he was
famously blondie a golden locked a
golden lock child but I should have been
he should have been rude s-sure maybe
she shouldn't have had an Irish accent
from the 7000 reviews I read an opinion
wait a minute you drive a car this
missus that keeps up all the time you
know they sort of ste through ya hands
up everybody here who's actually been
kissed on the lips by Brad Pitt
[Applause]